bonsoir un plaisir pour moi d'être
décrit sirigu la motivation de jeunes et
celle où j'écris toujours je suis avec
les jeunes je suis très heureux et
heureux de vous parler d'un même sujet
et malheureusement n'est pas très
heureux de nuit c'est la résistance aux
antibiotiques encore alors c'est quoi
les antibiotiques c'est une quand vous
savez c'est une classe thérapeutique qui
sert à faire boire et bien à traiter les
maladies infectieuses quand on a une
injection doit prendre un antibiotique
alors ce set grâce thérapeutique
j'aimerais que chacun d'entre nous
comprennent quel est son intérêt pour
l'humanité alors les antibiotiques comme
vous connaître comme vous savez le
premier antibiotique qui était une
découverte et la paix ni la pénicilline
qui a été découverte en 1928 par un
chercheur britannique qui s'appelait
alexandre fleming et après dans les
années 40 38 40
d'autres chercheurs ont travaillé pour
mettre en évidence l'intérêt de cette
molécule pour guérir les meubles et les
gens qui avaient des infections et en
tous ces chercheurs ont obtenu le prix
nobel de la médecine pour leurs
découvertes et bien sûr après ces
individus qu'on était industriels
et on a commencé à les allées à les
vendre à les fabriquer les vendre dans
le monde entier et ce qu'il faut savoir
moi même je n'ai pas vécu ça vous êtes
encore plus jeunes c'est que avant
l'arrivée de la pénicilline du premier
antibiotique l'humanité était vraiment
très très très malheureuse parce que il
y avait énormément de souffrance et
énormément de mortalité à chaque fois
qu'une femme accoucher elle avait
beaucoup de chances de mourir à cause
d'une infection
le bébé aussi avait beaucoup de chances
de mourir à cause de l'infection
on ne pouvait pas faire des opérations
chirurgicales sans avoir des mortalités
chacun qui faisait un accident ou une
blessure de guerre oui blessure banal
pouvait aussi avoir des risques de
mourir ou de souffrir très longtemps à
cause de la de tout simplement d'accord
alors avant de vous parler de résistance
j'aimerais vous expliquer des jeunes
ingénieurs très intelligent vous
expliquer comment ça se passe même si
vous n'êtes pas biologiste essayer d'y
arriver
et bien sachez que chaque individu
humain
il possède dans son organisme 10
puissance 13 cellules humaines et cet
organisme qui est constitué de 18 sont
réélus humaine il héberge 10 puissance
14 cellules microbiennes
c'est à dire que dans notre organisme on
a dix fois plus de cellules microbiennes
que des cellules humaines
ces cellules microbiennes ces bactéries
vous aller les trouver dans les cheveux
vous allez trouver sur la peau vous
allez trouver dans le tube digestif au
niveau des intestins et autres vous
allez aussi l'être
mais dont les voies génitales dans les
voies respiratoires il n'y a qu'une
petite partie de l'organisme
vous ne trouvez pas de bactéries ces
leçons lalinde et le liquide céphalo
rachidien
tout le reste est envahi par ces micro
donc quand je vous dis 10 puissance 14
bactéries ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire
100 mille milliards de bactéries et les
lois de la probabilité font que parmi
ces cent mille milliards de bactéries
vous allez avoir 99 99 % qui sont
sensibles chez un organisme qui n'a
jamais été exposée aux antibiotiques
mais vous avez forcément avoir 0 0 0 0 1
% de bactéries puissante résistance à
l'antibiotique quelle que soit cette
horrible et rien quand on expose
l'organisme inventivité autrement dit qu
on donne l'envié biotique à un être
humain qu'est ce qu'on fait ou un animal
et son prix on va tuer ou empêcher ces
bactéries 106 qui sont majoritaires ont
mal exemple étudier ou les empêcher se
multiplier et pendant ce temps vous avez
les bactéries résistantes qui était
minoritaire qui selui
et après le traitement qu est ce que
vous avez à travers une changement de
situation
les bactéries 106 qui étaient
majoritaires deviennent minoritaires et
l'homme et les bactéries résistantes qui
était minoritaire deviennent
majoritaires et c'est là que la la la la
la la résistance s'installe alors si
c'était que ça c'est bon aussi grave
le problème c'est que quand vous mettez
les bactéries en contact avec les
antibiotiques malev n'allait pas
développer la résistance contre un seul
antibiotique
mais il ne se rappelle la résistance
croisée qui fait que lorsque vous donnez
un antibiotique individus mais juste
donné un seul but
il peut développer la résistance entre
plusieurs zones du type ses terres les
bactéries deviennent résistantes à
plusieurs antibiotiques et
malheureusement on arrive aujourd'hui à
des situations très fréquents
ouvrons la passion qui ont une infection
qui est arrêté
ils sont résistants à tous les
antibiotiques qui existent aux autres
autrement dit on est en train de revenir
petit à petit vers toi vers l'est on
appelle les crèmes antibiotiques que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
appelle des reproches aux antibiotiques
c'est à dire aux malheurs de l'humanité
qui existait avant l'apparition des
antilles
donc voilà si vous roulez le problème de
la résistance
qu'est ce que c'est que le problème de
la de la vessie alors cette résistance
était 28 quotas cette résistance
malheureusement elle et elle est gérée
par des jeunes qu'on appelle les gènes
de résistance et c'est une résistance
savez ce que c'est qu'un c'est donc un
geste l'information génétique qui permet
à une cellule de fabriquer des monnaies
eh bien ces molécules qui vont être
fabriqués se sent pas raison des enzymes
les catalyseurs qui vont dégrader lundi
lieu dit voyez donc de la bactérie vre
on pourrait la tuer avec un outil
critique et ne dégrade ou alors des
jeunes qui vont permettre à les
bactéries
fabriqué en grâce à ces from hell va
refouler l'antibiotique à chaque fois
qu'ils pas pénétrer et c'est comme ça
que la résistance instinct est il que ça
ces jeunes ne restent pas dans leurs
bactéries miliciens serre et une fois
qu'ils ont été eux
encore une fois on a scellé cette
bactérie résistant qui procède cg et
bien cette bactérie et est capable de
transférer ses jets à votre mari rené
alizon si vous prenez dans un q vous
mettez 50 points de ma connaissance qui
est 50% de bactéries résistantes
qu'est ce que vous allez revoir et bien
au bout de quelques heures
toutes les bactéries vont devenir
résistantes pourquoi et bien parce que
chaque bactérie résistant va transférer
une copie de son gène de résistance à la
bactérie 106 et cc arrive
malheureusement lorsque un être humain
va prendre l outil multi cui mais c'est
aussi lorsqu'un être humain va prendre
une viande ou du lait ou un entre un
autre produit alimentaire qui contient
des bactéries des histoires si nous
mangeons des matériels existants est
bien certain que les résistants vont
transférer le
distance à aux bactéries sont dans notre
organisme et c'est comme ça que ça cesse
alors quelles sont les causes il y à
trois causes essentiellement la première
celle usage des antibiotiques chez l'un
et ça on n'y peut rien quand on est
malade on est obligé de prendre un
antibiotique sauf sauf que parfois en
prendre des antibiotiques alors que l'on
n'a pas besoin un coup de froid un petit
ru une petite fièvre passagère dont la
commande il antibiotiques ce n'est pas
automatique
l'autre raison autre cause de la
résistance et l'usagé des pesticides
savez les pesticides en agriculture on
hésite et 10,06 une coûte un peu cher
mais les agriculteurs ne vont utiliser
des pesticides que lorsque ils ont des
plantes mal mais là où c'est ultra
agressif qui le ronge c'est au niveau de
l'élevage des animaux d'élevage le
poulet
mais tiers mais or dans certains pays
etc le problème c'est que on ne va pas
bonne et on ne demande pas des
antibiotiques à des animaux malades
parce qu'ils sont malades mans en donne
des antibiotiques les animaux qui sont
pas pourquoi elle vient pour qu'ils
grossissent plus vite et ça c'est
vraiment scandaleux parce que pour que
les éleveurs soient satisfaits avec ses
animaux et bien en quelque sorte qu'on
expose la santé humaine et l'humanité à
ce grave fléau qui est la résistance aux
antilles
voilà donc clair ça c'est si vous voulez
cesser le promets alors quelles sont les
solutions préconisées par les autorités
internationales pour ça la première
solution bien sûr c'est la 106 la
sensibilisation et bien sûr c'est très
très très important de sensibiliser
c'est ce que nous sommes en train de
faire aujourd'hui et je pense qu'à
partir d'aujourd'hui chacun d'entre vous
va devenir un militant pour la cause de
quelques aux labos de préserver ce
patrimoine
il en fut autrement dit l'objectif c'est
une âme qui doit rester dans les mains
les médecins pour combattre les
infections sinon on risque de retourner
à l'être car antibiotiques et d'humanité
sera croyez moi vraiment très